oh
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
nine now that we are up under our bodies
regime my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
mangoes
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
[Applause]
is what you doing
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen do not adjust your
television it is really 2023 and for the
first time in history a president is
being indicted and will face criminal
charges this is all just such great
views such great news I was proven even
more right than I would have ever
imagined because apparently you know
there is actually igniting my father so
maybe I was wrong maybe prayer does work
like communist level of this is
great communist level
like communist level this is
[Music]
communist level
great orange leader Dear God
[Music]
forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donnie boy
Dear God
[Music]
I think that's about all we need to hear
more
whoa who really gives a crap about law
isn't this the most bizarre delivery
[Music]
Donald Trump Jr
delivered oh man episode
this prosecution isn't based on facts
or the law
how would he know them
be damned the Constitution be damned
your rice be Dan because well you hate
America what difference does it make
junior is just ranting uncontrollably
the hot take on Twitter was that these
guys are trying do this this is the hot
stupid take on Twitter over the weekend
like the dumbest take ever ever
I've never seen Junior like this and
I've seen Junior pretty hopped up
Bolshevik style I've never seen Junior
like this and I've seen Junior pretty
hopped up
I don't know I've never seen Junior like
this and I've seen you and you're pretty
hopped up Bolshevik style I've never
seen Junior like this and I've seen
Junior pretty hopped up pure witch
hunter
okay who really gives a crap about law
when you're weaponizing your office and
where everyone there agrees with you
then he went Donald Trump Donald Trump I
love Donald Trump and no more Drogba the
drop boxes are just so bad no more drop
boxes Dickinson hologic and cephe
cephahide
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
real Beauty had to give the American
people their voice back by building
something called truth truth essential
against Kate's law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the good some of the world's
greatest cricket players from suchin
tendulker to
Colleen
as the great religious teacher Swami
Vive come on what's that
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
United States thank you very much he was
awarded the broad star and the combat
infant trip and badge for his service we
have to keep our country gay perfect but
it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
law and auto look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
all right folks we're cutting it early
because we are moments away from Donald
Trump back from his arrest in New York
City in Florida and this is such a
serious event that I decided to wear my
glasses just to add elements of
professionalism to the entire stream we
certainly need that any way that we can
get it welcome to everybody who is just
joining us the president of the United
States Joe Biden opting not to even
comment about the arrest and indict of
the failed former president Donald Trump
and I have to tell you I don't need Joe
Biden to comment I like the fact that
Joe Biden is just saying I'm running the
country the decisions made by DA's and
prosecutors it has nothing to do with me
I have nothing about it to say and I
genuinely like to see that okay
everybody understand
what's going on I think I actually may
adopt that during the stream the only
issue is I can't see a damn thing when I
take my glasses off but there's this
thing that some news people really have
down where they just sort of
make a very
prescient point
and then they go back to the less
serious stuff as all of you may know
um no in all seriousness I can't even
see my monitors without these glasses on
so I'm going to have to probably keep
them on also my hair doing something
very strange back here listen guys it's
been a very long day let me see if I can
get this fixed up at all because this is
this could potentially lead to me
getting canceled again all right we have
no idea how long this wait oh sorry hold
on we have no idea how long this is
going to go when it's going to start
it's scheduled for 8 15 but Trump's
always late whether he will take
questions for the from the Press we
genuinely don't know what we do know is
that Donald Trump has been charged with
34 felonies now in terms of the prison
sentence that he could face
do you want me to give you like well I
guess I'll just kind of tell you all of
it it's being reported Trump could face
136 years in prison as legal experts
have actually told us it's
extraordinarily unlikely that he would
really face more than four because these
34 counts are all related to the same
act and so it's very unlikely that you
would get 34 consecutive for your
sentences it just doesn't make any sense
right so I'm not I'm not going to blow
smoke uh up everybody here
um and realistically I don't think that
he will do a single day
now that's just a prediction don't get
mad at me you can have an opinion about
that and I can have an opinion about
that and at some point we'll know the
truth I just don't think he'll do a
single day I don't believe he will do a
single day in prison okay so we are here
tomorrow on the podcast we're going to
have debriefing on all of this stuff
including the charges and all of the
different things so
um it's it's really been quite a day a
day that started
for me 13 hours ago if you can imagine
it if you can imagine it let's go to
Super Chat do you think enforce not
enforcing the gag order was
intentionally done well to some degree
even if you put a gag order on Trump
he'll just talk through it
so it is possible that the judge said
listen I don't really want to end up
bringing this guy in here for violating
uh the the terms I've set out
so therefore I'm just not even going to
put the gag order in place that's
certainly possible
um sir my call last week was subpoenaed
by Mike pillow for the Dominion lawsuit
happy surrender day absolutely hold on
where's my pillow over 54 countries have
now been taken by the machines Jonathan
says just get a pair of empty frames
then you can use lenses and your vision
will be normal and you can use the
frames as a prop well I normally wear I
normally wear contact lenses absolutely
folks today's coupon code we have
something very special going on and in
fact I do want to say thank you to Mark
Fillion as well as Jason sickmeyer
kicking us off and putting us at two we
also have twitch where we have one two
three four five
oh God there's Junior six seven eight
nine
10 11 people who signed up via twitch
Prime putting us at 13. the coupon code
is indicted but if you misspell the
coupon code indicated you save even more
remember when Trump published the truth
Central that he was being indicated so
we have the real coupon code which is
indicted saves you like 50 percent and
then we have the staged coupon code
indicated which saves you even more
today is a great day to sign up at
joinpakman.com if you like we are
celebrating that no one is above the law
we're not saying Trump must be guilty we
have something called due process unlike
these right Wingers who say jail Hillary
or Hillary or shillary or whatever they
call her these days and in indict this
right hey there was evidence for an
indictment I'm not saying jail Trump I
I'm saying due process let's see what
happens so if we are celebrating like I
believe you are that no one is above the
law coupon code indicted or coupon code
indicated either one works indicated
gives you the bigger discount all right
super chats continue pouring in do you
think a rhino named Mitt Romney ER will
comment on Trump's indictment I would be
interested in hearing what Romney says I
actually would would he go the route of
saying I'm not a trump fan but this is a
political attack or
would would Romney say something
different
sir oh okay no we already got that one
good all right so we're caught up as far
as that goes we have multiple multiple
feeds here this one we're going to close
because it's no good and this one is
trash okay this one's not bad Trump
expected any moment
live live live and here is Newsmax
talking about Nancy Pelosi they've got
Eric balling this guy on the left Rob
Schmidt joined the hate mob against me
last week you will be pleased to know
that they actually failed badly and this
is what ended up happening on uh on
YouTube you see these numbers folks the
hate mob sent Against Me by Don Jr and
everybody else Candace Owens of course
she she came after me wait where's my
Candace David Pacman does not have
she may be right but I don't know that
anyone has a soul I don't know if souls
are a real thing
so there Candace anyway they failed very
very badly failed very very badly
uh okay let's see what else we have oh
thanks to Mark Fillion for gifting
another subscription I appreciate that
if you'd like a free subscription go to
davidpackman.com free membership Desiree
Delong just gifted a subscription for
someone people are asking the same
series of questions in chat how long is
this going to go I have no idea when is
it going to start scheduled for 8 15
Eastern Will trump take questions from
the Press I don't know Will trump attack
the D.A or the judge I don't know but
probably
I would go with probably on that one
um that that's just sort of like my
guess at this point in time it is really
a pleasure to be back on Twitch and
seeing everybody
um a lot of folks we haven't seen for a
while looks like they're now trying to
prop the doors open so that Trump
doesn't have to hold the door for
himself many of you noticing that in
court earlier today nobody held the door
for Trump trump having to hold the door
for himself something he may uh may not
not be used to doing
voicemails are Absa absolutely uh
pouring in
um here's one guy who seems angry about
the indictment or something
David it's Alan from Jersey I'm watching
the bonus show and I cannot believe what
you're saying you sit there on your your
high horse
on the Ivory Tower so you're sitting on
the high horse and the horse that you're
sitting on is on the Ivory Tower saying
that's distracted driving is the worst
thing ever and you can't stand people
with their heads in their phones and you
know all the answers because you sitting
in the Ivory Tower and you just have to
send more oh my God oh my God all right
I'm done I gotta get away yes distracted
driving is a disaster folks I drive
around even in States like New York
where you're not allowed to drive around
like this or whatever people you you're
on the highway okay three lanes you see
someone in the fast lane going 15 miles
an hour under the speed limit I know
from a mile away that they're on their
phone
and then I pass them yes I admit it I
passed the middle in the Middle Lane
which is not how highways are supposed
to work and uh they're just on they're
not even looking they're just like this
they're just like this on their phone it
is an absolute disaster
disaster okay would it be interesting if
Trump came in and handcuffs it would
it actually would be kind of interesting
it'd be pointless but it but it would be
pretty interesting if he did and Trump
is expected in about uh 12 minutes big
thank you to Haley Brady Joe Rader Mark
Fillion David Cisco
Nathaniel crane ramar Jones and Rachel
Tate all of whom have uh just either
donated memberships or signed up
themselves did I see that Andrew taint
was released from prison I did or jail I
guess I did see it I don't really care I
don't I'm just not a fan I don't
whatever Jack says will I cover Chicago
mayoral and Wisconsin Supreme Court race
results tonight you know probably not
we're I'm on hour 14 for today and I've
still got to work on tomorrow's show
which will to some degree depend on what
happens over the next few hours so I
probably will not be covering that
tonight but maybe tomorrow
the Trump indictment is so long overdue
says Andrew he has been committing
crimes for decades
Tristan says appreciate the work David I
have many Christian friends zero had
concerns about your tweets your Tweet
just thought I'd pass along some
non-negativity thank You Tristan
if Trump ends up doing time at the
Mar-A-Lago facility will he tunnel out
through the sewage system maybe that's
why Trump has been advocating for high
flow toilets and maybe just widening of
all sewage uh pipe so that it could
maybe lead to an eventual Escape that's
interesting
Dominic said I messed up my first Super
Chat oh hold on we want to see what's
going on in the room here
uh here we go
is this still live yeah I kind of messed
up my first Super Chat hey David sir I
was Ultra busy at work all day any
chance you can get me up to speed with
the hearing did the judge put up a gag
order no gag order no gag order
the judge did not place a gag order
um and much speculation as as to why
arguing but no strength of the overall
okay so we're continuing to to follow
all of this stuff other super chats
based on your pbd interview do you not
believe there's a soul because there's
no polling data to suggest one exactly
Daniel yes very very accurate very
accurate
any chance of seeing you on leftovers H3
podcast soon I will go there anytime
they want
anytime Ethan wants to have me on I am
glad to go
big thank you to Greg Larson and Mark
Fillion as well as Matt batiata and Ryan
Ferguson and of course the great Greg
Curtis folks today's coupon code is
indicted you all know what it means you
can also use the coupon code indicated
which is extra special and an even
bigger discount if you can imagine here
are more people coming in a lot of big
strong guys with tears in their eyes we
are waiting for Donald Trump due to
speak nine minutes from now here is the
right side broadcasting stream let's
just listen to it very briefly many in
that they had no surprises and therefore
no case virtually every legal pundit has
said that there's no case here there was
nothing done illegally now we're seeing
that kind of as a common theme across
all social media networks in fact I just
saw one of the major fake newses and I
don't know which one now
these people are a joke one of the
things I do wonder about with this
broadcaster whose name I actually don't
know I don't know why you would pick
someone with such terrible diction
to be a broadcaster you know and it's
not about making fun of people I just
don't get the play with picking someone
with such terrible addiction to speak
it's it's confusing that that's all I'm
saying I just don't know that I get it
thanks and welcome to Sabrina Lee
Deirdre white Jacob Reeves and Jason
cubitt who just signed up on my website
the website did collapse earlier under
the massive load of people trying to
sign up Mike pillow has entered to Great
Applause there is pillow we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines over 54 countries have now been
taken by the machines Mike pillow and
all sorts of Mac you know what's really
funny
in sort of like serious places there are
entourages and characters that end up
just sort of being in proximity to power
with Trump it's like all morons where
you've got like pillow is showing up and
Marjorie Taylor green is there and the
guy from right side broadcasting who I
guess is dating Marjorie Taylor green is
there it's it's all really crazy because
it's just such silliness in every way
um okay we're continuing to uh to await
Donald Trump very very powerfully
there's a guy with a red hat which
people love to see welcome to Melanie
Hall Joy Bailey and Lisa Rader as well
as Mark Fillion putting us at 40 for the
evening Trump do any moment let's see if
we can squeeze in another voicemail or
two there is pillow look at this he
tested it and didn't even go into court
apparently uh president okay
uh let's see what else we've got here
hi David
um
a year for a couple years now
um I'm watching the coverage on TV about
uh Donald Trump's indictment yes
everyone on TV is claiming that he looks
sad defeated and dejected but I don't
buy it his ego is loving all the
attention and coverage the only image
that looked real was the angry scholar
probably because he knew the judge held
more power than him in that moment
absolutely true hard to disagree very
very hard uh
hard to disagree with that
uh all right let's see what else we've
got here
uh
uh other voicemails let's see what we
have
hi David this is joffer from the Philly
suburbs uh I followed your live stream
during Trump's arraignment and uh
indictment review of the charges on
Tuesday afternoon and uh amidst all of
the um
celebrations and jovial attitude of uh
of your many many fans myself included
notice quite a few people
um very enthusiastically uh bringing on
uh plays on the massive dumps oftentimes
in uh in in graphic detail and uh as a
physician I just wanted to
um make this aware make everyone aware
on this platform
um is that um with all the talk of
massive dumps it's important that once
you hit 45 you schedule a colonoscopy
that increase in rates of colorectal
carcinoma even among uh people in their
20s and 30s so even if you haven't had
that blown out those birthday candles if
you notice any uh atypical nature of
one's massive dumps all right you
absolutely reach out to your doctor if
that's the case and very much appreciate
hearing from all of the physicians in
our audience geez things are getting
really really wild here as we stand by
for Donald Trump uh welcome to really
dude as well as d-loms for the twitch
Prime subscriptions numbers 48 and 49
Trump do any moment you may recall that
last time Trump did an event at
Mar-A-Lago I believe that the last big
event like this
was when he announced he was running
and
um people were just like walking out
during the event and security was like
trying to prevent people from walking
out it was really really wild stuff so
we'll see if that happens tonight sort
of a different scene that's for sure but
we will remains to be seen I think is
the point remains to be seen
uh okay let's see
what else do we have
David Patton is not a night at the round
table because Pac-Man's a little titty
baby loser okay that's the Alex Jones
impersonator I guess globalist
internationalist Trotsky socialist yeah
[Music]
um
let's see here
hey I joined up with you this morning
when you were trying to get 250
Birds and now I can't seem to sign on so
that I can get on to watch your show
that's starting in about five minutes oh
you don't need to sign on any this is
just on YouTube you don't need to sign
on anywhere just go to YouTube and
you'll be you'll be absolutely fine
it'll be it'll be no problem whatsoever
um okay let's look at a couple different
things that have been taking place here
just a little bit of an audio feed
um let's see here and see what we have
um Trump arriving at Mar-A-Lago while
Kerry Lake Ronnie Jackson and others are
in the outdoor dining area
we saw these folks arrive
yeah the Trump attorney news conference
was pretty funny
uh we'll talk about that tomorrow
the bikers are there
Eric Trump post video of his dad on the
way to Mar-A-Lago
oh my God
that's a weird way of doing thumbs up
did you guys see that what's he doing
with his wrist
huh
I have to tell you I've never actually
seen that before that's that's very very
interesting
um what else do we have here rapper
Forgiato blow is at Mar-A-Lago Trump
rapper what does that even mean when you
found me
that guy's eyes are also almost swollen
shut that's weird a lot of weird stuff
going on here indictment party at
Mar-A-Lago
it's it's all really really weird
people are filming which suggests that
maybe Trump is about to speak I don't
know
people getting their uh cameras out
during updates about this particular all
right so we're still standing by
man what a cult what a cult thanks to
Harry white Kevin John
Ignacio Patsy as well as Anthony Jones
for signing up on my website today's
coupon code is indicted the code
indicated will also work and actually
gives you an even even bigger discount
believe it or not
um okay
well I I continue to see a lot of the
same questions don't know how long Trump
will speak don't know if he will take
media questions
scheduled to start in one minute
your guess is as good as mine as to
whether he will start on time
Reuben asks via Super Chat thoughts on
Trump's call to action tonight will here
won't he if you mean call for for
protesters to protest
honestly I have no idea at this point I
don't know what the guy is capable of I
genuinely do not know
David so glad you aren't falling to the
hate mob me and my co-worker were almost
devastated when we started to watch the
April first video I listened to you on
my drive to work daily and also value
you more than I realized you know one of
the great things about the April Fool's
joke was so many people wrote to me and
said
it is that Alina Haba Trump's attorney I
think it is so many people wrote to me
and said David when you did the April
Fool's joke where you claimed to be
canceling I realized how much I value
the show and it decide I I decided to
sign up because the idea of it being
gone really was uh impactful which is an
interesting thing to hear
Cody says look at all the cult members
apparently it's someone gets arrested in
the Republican Party America turns into
a third world socialist Marxism or was
it Marxist socialist or what these
people are clown shoes says Cody
wow
a lot of passion tonight
a Keith
says love your content coverage and
content but my husband came up to me
crying with tears in his eyes about your
Cheesesteak reviews love your work from
Philly I don't remember what did I say
that I just don't really love cheese
steak Yeah
it's not my favorite
if Trump is convicted will a secret
service protection go with him or will
he just get house arrest I believe if
Trump is sentenced that he will get
house arrest remains to be seen that we
are that is very very far from where we
are at this point in time I say we don't
worry about it can we get an update on
your baby's eating habits yeah she's
she's not she hasn't rejected anything
today she had for breakfast some
beautiful oatmeal with Greek yogurt
and uh blackberries
ate the entire thing
for lunch she had
um Spanish tortilla Which I made from
scratch of course I just don't salt it
and then I add salt to my portions uh
love the Spanish tortilla also has been
on an avocado and hummus toast
um Trend she actually likes avocado
hummus toast so much that when it starts
to sort of like disintegrate in her hand
the last bit of of bread she starts
sobbing quite literally sobbing and
um what else
she had a beautiful Korean beef stew the
other day that I made uh she's accepting
everything right now and I know that
that will change I know that there will
be a phase there will be a phase where
uh she will start to reject food
and I'm ready for it I'm ready for it
Jonathan says the U.S will be joining a
fantastic Club of countries that has
indicted their former leaders 78 other
countries check axios for more lovely
statistics on that
sir this music has to be his own people
trolling him besides the fact that
they're most likely open domain
I think you make a great dad David keep
up the good work that's a message from
fungal spore always great to hear from
fungal spore big thank you to the one
two three four five six seven additional
people who just grabbed memberships at
joinpakman.com putting us at 68. next
will be 69.
um oh also thanks to Frank stanklin for
the twitch Prime subscription you are
subscriber number 69 today let's listen
to
uh let's listen to like a couple more
voicemails
hello this is James from Hawaii we're
walking across the pond here and
celebrating it's 2 15 P.M
cheers beautiful
great to hear from folks
all over
hey David it's Jeannie from Florida I
had a really quick thing I want to tell
you it's kind of funny you were just
playing the clip of Donald Trump
thriving up to Mar-A-Lago and uh Eric
Kemp was recording him and his tiny
hands giving thumbs up to all of his
supporters and all that and if you take
notice his shoulder pad my husband
pointed this out his shoulder pads are
so giant they look like they're like six
inches thick of like memory foam
try to make him look like a big strong
man yeah you've got to check it back out
check it out it's hilarious
let's go back to that where was that
Eric Trump video
Eric Trump
here it is oh my God yeah look at those
shoulder pads that's thicker than
football pads actually that is actually
that's a very astute observation I like
that that is completely true that does
like look like memory foam or maybe it's
like a my pillow a shoulder pad that
Trump wears that's super interesting I
admit I did not notice that before I did
not notice that before but it is
something else
um let's see what else we have here from
people in the audience the most
important people
hi David I hope this indictment of trump
gives all of his voters the absolute
creeps so Karen McDougall do you know
who that is yes neither did I nobody
knows who knows who that is in fact I
mistakenly thought that was
uh Stephanie glofford Stormy Daniels
real name the reason nobody knew this is
because this is what he's being charged
for he suppressed this information to
make himself look better
that's a very very complicated voicemail
from a very very chaotic caller who's
been calling for a long time but I do
appreciate it Joey Cerrone says via
Super Chat we should all get indicted
who knew it was such a great thing yeah
it's funny they they are simultaneously
claiming that this indictment is the
best possible thing that could happen to
Trump and also and also that uh it's an
absolute travesty and terrible
um let's see uh
uh friend of mine is at the airport he
says
no one is talking about the Trump
indictment fascinating
fascinating all right well that's that's
good to know is that a New York airport
I think maybe that's the uh that's the
relevance people just report to stuff to
me it's very interesting thanks to
Deborah Bryant and Jonathan Olson for
signing up at joinpackman.com new
members 73 and 74. super chats
continuing to come in
um have you paid any attention to the
chaos at the Tennessee Capitol this week
three Dems getting booted for protesting
in in favor of gun reform yes in fact
the lead Story the lead story on today's
David Pacman Show podcast
was what is happening in Nashville
Tennessee I hope everybody here is
subscribed to the audio podcast it is
completely and totally free even if you
don't listen to it please subscribe
because it really helps us in the
rankings and the ratings if you can
subscribe to our audio podcast on
whatever platform you use and leave us a
nice review even if you never listen to
the damn thing and just watch on YouTube
um I would very very much appreciate it
Travis says thank you for your
compassionate coverage about alcoholism
I hope your channel keeps rising in a
way that blows your mind
well I hope so more people continuing to
enter there is Eric prump who recently
struggled to buy Tylenol at literally a
CVS
um next to his wife Lara Lara Trump
Laura Jason Miller who ran getter for a
while is behind Lara Lara Laura Trump as
you can see there is Jason Miller
everybody clapping for each other
literally saluting he used to run social
media in the Trump white house so we got
a trump inner World fixtures like I said
yep so Trump expected any moment here
uh let's see if we have other feeds that
are coming in number of different feeds
uh yeah make sure by the way folks if
you're watching on YouTube right now and
you look down and the Subscribe button
is enabled meaning you're not subscribed
folks please please this is let if you
have cable you're giving four bucks a
month to Fox News
the least we can ask for is to slam that
subscribe button over on YouTube it's a
beautiful beautiful number uh but I
think it could get better imagine if we
got to 1.69 million tonight that would
really really really be something else
as we continue to stand by for Trump
let's listen to the sights and sounds
[Music]
quite an ambiance
all right and this is Andrew Kraft here
uh yet again we want to thank you all
for being with us here on this yeah
thank you
thank you thank you other super chats
Trump absolutely should not take
questions but it would be delicious if
he does oh I really hope Trump takes
questions I really hope he does
David sir thank you for the coverage
well thank you
now more than ever your work is so
important keep up the good work Mart
thank you and thank you for all the
gifted subscriptions you have donated
thank you
there was a black cat crossing the road
in Ireland earlier I think that should
be indicated we can't have it even
sleepy Joe knows that and Don Jr looks
so creepy here is Donald Trump let's
listen to what he has to say
[Music]
they even play the country song when
this is just like a post arrest event
I'm not loving the the video quality
here let's just see if we can find you
something better this does seem better
to me right here this is coming just one
week after he's suggested if he were to
be charged there could be potential
death and destruction and there is
concern around the words the judge
articulated day all right so we are
going to be hearing from Donald Trump
very very soon big thank you to Jennifer
Rhodes Patton Davis
Michael bu Tammy Estep Jeffrey Medina
and Jason sickmeyer for the six
subscriptions we will hear from Donald
Trump shortly I have no idea whether
this is going to be a long or a short
speech whether he will take questions we
just don't know we just don't know the
judge did ask as was reported that the
divisive rhetoric be kept to a minimum
hard to imagine that's going to happen I
have to say a huge thank you to this
individual aquatic aquatic borealis
for a 400 Canadian Super Chat do you
believe Trump would have been convicted
during the impeachment if the voting had
been secret ballots and have we
considered the wider implications of
this sort of thing cardboard box reform
might be a solution I don't know I've
been asked that before I think it's
certainly more likely but I don't know I
don't know by the way where is Melania
why isn't Melania standing by her man
very confusing folks I must say in a
conservative movement
former president Donald Trump taking the
stage now for these remarks let's listen
in
you're right
this is a very serious cult very serious
cult I hope people know that
thank you very much everybody and we
have to save our country
God bless you all God bless you all
okay and I never thought anything like
this
could happen in America never thought it
could happen
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it it's
already insane
it's already deranged I think the
Democrats
spied in my campaign remember that they
did not never they attacked me with an
onslaught of fraudulent investigations
Russia Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two the illegal and
unconstitutional raid on Mar-A-Lago
right here
[Music]
the FBI and doj relentlessly pursuing
Republicans
the unconstitutional changes to election
laws by not getting approvals from state
legislators
the millions of votes illegally stuffed
into ballot boxes and all caught on
government cameras
and just recently the FBI and doj in
collusion with Twitter and Facebook
in order not to say anything bad about
the hunter Biden laptop from Hell which
exposes the Biden family as criminals in
which
according to the pollsters would have
made a 17 point difference
in the election result patently absurd
and we needed a lot less than that like
about 16 absurd nine
it would have been in our favor
not my favor our favor because our
country is going to hell
what the heck just happened intelligence
agents that was weird who said Hunter
Biden's laptop was Russian
disinformation
it didn't exist it was Russian
disinformation remember that
and that was all confirmed strongly by
the FBI
when they all knew that it wasn't
Russian disinformation
and so much more our elections were like
those of a third world country and now
this massive election interference at a
scale never seen before in our country
beginning with the radical left to
George Soros back prosecutor Alvin Bragg
of life
[Applause]
he would get president Trump I gotta get
him I'm going to get him this is a guy
campaigning
you want to get president Trump at any
cost and this before he knew anything
about me didn't know a thing about me he
was campaigning
as it turns out virtually everybody that
has looked at this case including rhinos
and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime
and that it should never have been
brought
it
even people that
aren't big fans have said it they said
this is not the right thing to do
it's an insult to our country as the
world is already laughing at us for so
many other reasons like our open borders
they mostly laugh at us because we
elected Trump in 2016. that's the big
joke Where We Left Behind American
citizens 85 billion dollars worth of
the best military equipment in the world
lost 13 magnificent young lives and far
too many
to mention that are so badly hurt with
the loss of arms and legs and facial
obliteration
the most embarrassing time in our
country's history in my opinion
then our give up on energy Independence
and even energy imagine getting arrested
and talking about lies about energy
Independence
we had this all just three years ago our
raging
crime statistics if you look in
democrat-run cities numbers the likes of
which we have never seen before
the open threats by various countries
of the use of nuclear weapons
something never mentioned or discussed
by outside Nations during the Trump
Administration in which
could very well lead under the Biden
administration's leadership
he seems off tonight doesn't he anybody
noticing that three can happen
we're not very far away from it believe
it or not
an economy that has been crippled by the
biggest inflation we have seen in more
than 60 years and a military that I use
to defeat Isis in four weeks they said
it would take four years
four weeks to kill al-baghdadi and
solomonie
that has now gone woke at the top Levels
by trying to indoctrinate everyone down
to the lowest ranking Patriot give me a
break dude but now they have really
stepped up their reference by
indicting
the 45th president
of the United States who received
75 million votes which is more than any
sitting president what's the connection
between votes and being able to get
indicted I'm trying to remember
and in the wings they've got a local
racist Democrat district attorney in
Atlanta who is doing everything in her
power to indict me let's hope over an
absolutely perfect phone call even more
perfect than the one I made with the
president of Ukraine remember a kid kept
saying that's a perfect call and he was
wrong this one was more perfect
nobody said sir you shouldn't say that
many people are just voluntary I'm sorry
or hung up and discussed because of
something I inappropriately said
because nothing was said wrong in fact
at the end of the call we agreed to
continue our conversation about election
fraud did we an election fraud
specifically in Georgia
at a later time many people on the phone
including lots of lawyers nobody found
anything wrong with that perfect call
until a book promotion to her Trump has
a way of killing sucking the energy out
of a crowd like I've never seen anyone
do look at that this fake case was
brought only to interfere with the
upcoming 2024 election
and it should be dropped immediately
immediately
then you have a radical left lunatic
known as a bomb thrower
who is harassing hundreds of my people
day after day
over the boxes hoax you know the boxes
as we call it
just so everyone knows I come under
what's known as the presidential records
act which was designed and approved by
Congress long ago just for this reason
under the ACT I'm supposed to negotiate
with Nara the National Archives and
Records Administration
which as of this date is a radical left
trouble making organization that red
flags the Constitution of the United
States and the Bill of Rights has yeah a
couple things uh this person is asking
via Super Chat whether Mercy bands are
available tonight I we will oblige if
people need a mercy band because this is
too absurd our moderators can help uh
second thing just about everything Trump
is saying is a lie or at least deceptive
I just hope people understand that and
some are all of the documents that I
openly and in very plain sight
brought with me to Mar-A-Lago from our
beautiful white house just as virtually
every other president has done in the
past
okay we've been listening into the
former president as he makes remarks at
Mar-A-Lago we initially took this event
thinking he was going to talk about the
indictment today being charged with okay
please don't I'm just trying to hear
what he's saying
but there is no criminality okay the
audio there is terrible let's try this
one
the next thing I know we were rated by
many gun toting FBI agents who took
whatever they wanted including my
passports and medical records
it was a completely legal search warrant
you all know that never heard of such a
raid before we can't even believe it who
would think that that could happen today
I immediately thought of the fourth
amendment that protects against
unreasonable search and seizure
justice system
has become Lawless
they're using it now in addition to
everything else to win elections
apparently they're not looking at me
through the view of the non-criminal
presidential records act they came up
with a new one this is a new one
and they're looking at me through the
Espionage Act think of that how does
that sound of 1917 where the penalty
is death
even though that is absolutely nothing
to do with openly taking boxes of
documents and mostly clothing and other
things to my home he mostly took clothes
which President Obama has done the
bushes have done do you realize that
it was fine there were a hundred
classified documents but there were also
500 shirts nobody gives them credit for
that 33
000 emails and that was okay
but nobody's done it like Joe Biden
this lunatic special prosecutor named
Jack Smith I wonder what it was prior to
a change
who others of his ilk say
he is even worse than they are
is only looking at Trump yet Joe Biden
took massive amounts more documents even
removed many boxes to Chinatown
you believe that she's got 10 million
dollars from China where did that come
from I guess they were banking on
Hunter's expertise
and had others stored in unsecured
offices in Pennsylvania and strewn all
over his garage floor where his now very
famous Corvette
is also stored all over the floor
including classified documents oh God
but that's okay
perhaps the most important yeah he has
1850 boxes in Delaware
which he is refusing to give up I don't
know guys he's sounding pretty innocent
to me
it's obstruction
as president I have the right to
declassify documents and the process is
automatic
if I take them with me it's automatic
Declassified
Biden was vice president
he had absolutely no right to declassify
as vice president
he doesn't come under the non-criminal
presidential records act he comes under
the very criminal Federal records act
unfortunately for him but it's not going
to matter because they don't follow the
law
which is why is he breathing like that
it's very strange he had classified
documents that he took while he was a
senator
which is absolutely inexcusable and
other Senators including Democrats
are outraged but he's not being harassed
and hounded
like the people
who work for me are
in fact they seem to have forgotten
about his documents entirely so many
thousands and thousands okay with him
they like to say that I'm obstructing
which I'm not
because I was working with Nara very
nicely until the raid on my home
but the gist of this is basically like
I'm super innocent I'm as as innocent as
anybody's ever been why many documents
were located in Chinatown can't explain
it why were they in Chinatown I don't
know
lastly I'm under investigation
this time a civil investigation by
another racist in reverse
who also campaigned on I will get Trump
I will get them
this was our campaign never ran for
office I will get him
her name is Leticia James
[Applause]
and she proclaimed while campaigning
quote I look forward to going into the
Office of the Attorney General every
single day suing him and then going home
before she knew me
she announced what is fueling my soul
right now is Trump
and that she had her eyes on Trump Tower
those eyes are focused on Trump town
didn't know the young lady
she even assured her supporters in an
election promise that we're going to
definitely sue him we're going to be a
real pain in the ass
he's going to know my name personally
and then she claimed that I was an
illegitimate president I think you ever
think of that with all
with all we did with all we did on
energy with all we did on the military
on taxes biggest tax cuts in history
biggest regulation Cuts in history
right to try
people able to get anybody know what the
hell
what on Earth
a video started playing
and my audio cut and I could not even
control what was on the screen that was
bizarre
I'm wondering if antifa got into my
stream deck kids are going to be
investigated she said
and that of her family
and his family
because we're going after his family and
we're going after them hard
this is all before entering office and
all before knowing anything at all about
me but you're gonna get me
this is why along with unrelenting crime
so many people and companies are leaving
New York
she said that I falsified my financial
statements but in fact we're proving and
we'll prove that my financial statements
were substantially more than we
submitted not less
and in all cases have a strong
disclaimer clause in them which tells
the institutions that may look at that
if they want to
not to rely on the state but they've got
a problem we told them they were bogus
because number one I'm
very under leverage they can't believe
it all the stuff they read and gave
and have very little debt relative to
the value of assets
and importantly not One bank has lost
even one dollar she was investigating me
to save Banks they have very good
lawyers
but they didn't lose a dollar with us
during this period of time
in fact the banks
we're talking about
made almost 200 million dollars off
Donald Trump
and they like me very much
we never missed a payment never got a
default notice had a great relationship
with all of them I don't need Banks they
have a lot of cash
I built a great business with my family
built a fantastic business
yeah
oh boy here we go with the water
[Applause]
I have a son here who's done a great job
and I have another son here who's done a
great job
Tiffany
and Ivanka and baron will be great
someday he's tall there you go and he's
smart
but I have a great family and they've
done a fantastic job and we appreciate
it very much they've gone through hell
[Applause]
so she's suing me over banks that
weren't defrauder when she should be
focused on violent crime that's driving
people out of the state
this is a persecution not an
investigation she's put our family
through hell it's cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to defend
but our heads are held very very high
they want to settle the case but I want
no part of that whoa
he's going to go to try so here we are
now
[Applause]
it's where we were today
in a city that was so gracious four or
five years ago
but now we're there
spend time there today as you possibly
read
with a local failed district attorney
charging a former president of the
United States for the first time in
history
on a basis that every single pundit and
legal analysis there is not the word yes
there's no case they kept saying there's
no case
virtually everyone
but it's far worse than that because he
knew there was no case
that's why last week he delayed for a
month and then immediately took that
back what through this ridiculous
indictment together came out today
everybody said this is not really an
indictment there's nothing here
my lawyers came to me and they said
there's nothing here they're not even
saying what you did they said sir the
criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive
amounts of grand jury information
there you go that'll go well
for which he should be prosecuted or at
a minimum
and Alvin Bragg's wife confirmed a
report that claim to her has Trump
nailed on felonies Trump demanding that
the prosecutor be indicted that's
interesting
his chief prosecutor who represented the
Democrats and crooked Hillary Clinton
and
a firm run by Chuck Schumer's brother
Robert
he quit the firm in order to go to work
in the D.A office in order to get Trump
can you imagine that Hillary Clinton's
lawyer Democrat lawyer Democrat firm
ultimately he
quit as Chief prosecutor because Bragg
didn't think he had a case think of that
same guy that brought this ridiculous
thing today
yeah during his investigation
this prosecutor named Mark pomerance
wrote and published a book
saying all sorts of privileged things
and has been very strongly rep really
reprimanded he was reprimanded so
strongly very glitchy I've never seen
anything like it at probably the end of
it
but
what he did was probably very illegal
very very very strongly reprimanded
even district attorney Bragg was furious
with him they were having a tremendous
fight in the office because of it
not exactly the fire and passion I
expected from Trump given the
circumstances I have to say quit because
they thought president Trump was being
treated very unfairly how about that
isn't that great oh I love them I'd like
to meet them
I'd like to meet them
the DA's office
even had a web page
meet the team of Executives who have
done this to president Trump that was
the title isn't that nice they
immediately had to take it down
meanwhile overall crime in New York was
up 30 percent last year
much more than that the year before with
felony assaults robberies and burglaries
all up by massive massive numbers
not the same place that I know not the
same place that you know
and this is where we are right now I
have a trump-hating judge
with the trump-hating wife and family oh
he's attacking the judge my daughter
worked for Kamala Harris
and now receives money from the Biden
Harris campaign and a lot of it
we recently had another trial and the
same judge told the fine man who worked
for me for many many years
that if you admit your guilt
you will be in jail for 90 days
but if you don't
if we go through a trial and you're
found guilty you're going away for 10
years and maybe longer
which for a 75 year old man with a great
family
really means life
what the prosecutors and judge did to
that man I will never forget
because it's right out of the old Soviet
Union that's where we are
meaning that's bad
and you won't even have to serve the 90
days you'll walk free
and they say that to many of my
employees
we have this Jack Smith lunatic
threatening people every single day
through his Representatives
they're threatening jail terms
but talk about Trump and you'll go free
this is where we are as a nation who
would have thought
they can't beat us at The Ballot Box so
they try and beat us
they just beat you badly at The Ballot
Box that's the country in which we live
however right now the USA is a mess
our economy is crashing inflation is out
of control Russia has joined with China
can you believe that
Saudi Arabia has joined with Iran
China Russia Iran and North Korea have
formed together
is a menacing and destructive Coalition
would have never happened
if I were your president would never
have happened
nor would Russia attacking Ukraine have
happened all of those lives would be
saved all of those beautiful cities
would be standing
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard
which will be our greatest defeat
frankly in 200 years there will be no
defeat like that
that will take us away from being even a
great power
if you took the five worst Presidents in
the history of the United States
and added them up
they would not have done near the
destruction to our country as Joe Biden
and the Biden Administration have hard
to believe hard to believe
[Applause]
incredibly we are now a failing Nation
we are a nation in Decline
and now these radical left lunatics want
to interfere with our elections by using
law enforcement
we can't let that happen
[Applause]
crowd sort of into that
with all of this being said
and with a very dark cloud
over our Beloved Country
I have no doubt nevertheless
that we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you and
God bless America thank you very much
everybody thank you
no questions
[Applause]
[Music]
very weird event huh
[Applause]
[Music]
what a strange event
wow
see if we can get a better shot at
what's going on here not this one
is it done that one's delayed
[Music]
[Applause]
up about 30 minutes of speaking here in
Mar-A-Lago going over much of what we've
kind of learned over the last couple
weeks in terms of this case of being a
massive Witch Hunt that that we've never
seen anything like before we know we've
had a few technical issues during this
broadcast I want to apologize for that
obviously not on YouTube for strike
reasons and courts we've had some
technical issues with Rumble uh so those
of you that are joining us now perhaps
on Facebook getter the truth social our
app we certainly appreciate you tuning
in for that I want to thank one of our
sponsors tonight when it comes to coffee
when it comes to celebrating America
okay oh man what a weird weird weird
situation we are in at this point in
time it it really is just a strange and
bizarre thing
uh so there it is there are the
statements from Donald Trump
um he says he's innocent and uh he says
something about Afghanistan and uh you
know the D.A is bad and
everybody's bad the judge is bad Biden's
bad Hunter Biden's bad Hillary's bad
Obama's bad Chuck Schumer's brother is
definitely bad
um I mean it's I don't know guys I don't
know it's it's all crazy
um am I going to get those Trump gold
coins do I even think they're real gold
yeah I really couldn't tell you I really
couldn't tell you you gotta love how
deep a hole he's digging for himself yet
to some degree Trump tried to distract
from today's indictment by talking about
his other crimes
it's it's it's really beyond belief it
is truly beyond belief this was a cut
down rally speech right is it am I crazy
or does it seem like he just has the one
script yeah this was just his standard
speech just a little shorter without the
transphobia
it's basically it
stewards is David sir keep up the good
work you're the only thing keeping me
sane today I appreciate that but what
what a strange event what a strange
event I don't even get it
it's just all I don't even I thought he
was I thought it was going to be a press
conference and he was going to take
questions instead he just did like a cut
down
of version of his rally speech and the
crowd
wasn't even really very into it I don't
know if you noticed that which was
another kind of strange thing
to behold that that is what it is all
right folks it's been a very very long
day okay someone from Uruguay wants me
to read their message saying Pac-Man
okay well I'm reading it now this this
I've I see your message thank you I
appreciate that love Uruguay have
visited
there is Marjorie Trader green
exiting or going somewhere I don't know
and she is a very repulsive very very
repulsive apparently now dating the
right side broadcasting guy which is
weird there's Carrie Lake
Carrie Lake and Marjorie Taylor green I
think don't like each other but in very
close proximity to each other
interestingly enough
some guy taking a picture with Carrie
Lake and you've got
um just a
what a cast of characters what a cast of
characters here
all right folks we will be back tomorrow
as Mike pillow glad handing and holding
Court what a day an incredible day we
will see everybody tomorrow thank you
for joining me ladies and gentlemen do
not adjust your television it is really
2023 and for the first time in history a
president is being indicted and will
face criminal charges this is all just
such great news such great news I was
proven even more right than I would have
ever imagined because apparently you
know there is actually igniting my
father so great orange maybe I was wrong
maybe prayer does work
like communist level this is
great communist level this is
[Music]
Dear God
forbid Donnie boy God forbid Donny boy
great orange leader dear God
God forbid Donnie boy God